[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
free review of the witcher season two so
just to put
on notice
the press only got sent the first six
episodes out of eight for the season we
will not be sent the last two so we're
gonna be seeing the last two episodes
with everybody when it comes out next
friday so this is only based on the
first six episodes but
oh my god so
i'm someone that is a huge witcher fan
from the video games and then i
really enjoyed season one i wasn't blown
away i had a lot of issues with it
but
the things i had issues with in season
one were all fixed in season two and
everything i thought they could do
better in season one they did better in
season two i have never
in a long time seen such a step up in
quality from one season to another and
you can see how much money they put into
this season that they're really
investing into the witcher netflix which
is great but things that stood out to me
the cinematography is way better this
season
the production design like usual still
great but what i really love to see was
the makeup and hair here was done so
well and what i mean by that is
there's no more goofiness this season uh
a lot of it feels more like the witcher
world and everyone just looks better how
their costumes are and the feel of it
and it's amazing the wonders you can do
by just having tris now have red hair it
just makes all the difference little
details like that and it's the little
details i got right
this season compared to last
and what i love is
two things i was actually three things
that hurt season one for me where there
wasn't enough geralt that we got away
from him a lot there wasn't enough
horror
maybe there wasn't even enough action
and that the storyline could get
confusing so what they decided to do
this season was they ramp up the action
they totally ramp up the horror i mean
there are parts that are purely
terrifying in this season
and that's what i really wanted last
season so it's happy to see it here but
i mean it's like exorcist level
scary haunting of hill house level
scares
for sure and what i mean by the action
is the sequences are so good and you're
getting a lot of action you're getting
action every single episode and it's all
justified and it's not over the top
either but
the big change you're gonna see critics
talking about today
is that it's a linear story now it's not
this jumping timelines and trying to
figure out where you are they just said
you know what we're doing it completely
linear and to me it works
so much better for this type of show
with the witcher it just does you might
be hesitant about that maybe you like
that it was kind of you know all over
different timelines last season i could
see that argument but trust me when you
watch how they do it this season it just
makes it so much more intense and keeps
you on the edge of the seat but what's
the most important thing they had to get
down was siri and geralt's relationship
and now them being together and that
just takes the show to the next level it
is going to be a relationship on
television that is going to be maybe the
most popular relationship that people
are going to want to tune in for for
years to come and it's so well done and
obviously henry cavill is amazing as
geralt there's no complaints there for
me i think he nails it and he's amazing
here again
but the standout for the season so far
for me is freya allen as siri
oh my god she's so good and
she's so good with henry cavill here but
she has to have some big scenes this
season she's given so much more to do
and to me her character storyline is the
most interesting this season and i'm not
going to go into detail about that
because i'm not spoiling anything here
but from someone who loved the video
games uh and i love witcher 3 which i
had played again recently
i loved it so much i even got a nerdy
tattoo of the witcher here but
you know
they really do a lot of things i believe
for video game fans this season because
i know it's based off the books the show
but the way they make it look
you're gonna get a lot of just things
that remind you of being in that world
and now seeing it come to life so
beautifully and it's it's great and of
course our other main player here in
jennifer
really can't get anything with her
because there's so many spoilers
involving her character this season but
again she's great as ever to watch and
having
us really have those three main
characters still be the center here of
geralt siri and jennifer just works
great the score is great
i don't want to hype this up anymore
because it's already super hyped this
show uh rightfully so but
it's to me a huge step up from season
one where season one that was like a b
pretty good but the creator who i've
interviewed lauren schmidt history quite
hope to get to interview for season two
crossing my fingers there's a giant
centipede is what i'm looking at i'm not
going to put that on camera because it's
terrifying but it is looking at me while
i'm doing this i'm trying to just look
over there but i'm hoping i get to
interview again you can check out my
first interview with her where she talks
about where the show might go after
season one so maybe i'll give you a
little hint of what you could see for
season two but i'm so impressed with the
decision she made and the effort put
into this season every single scene is
great here i was so blown away so i'm
giving these first six episodes a
9.1
let me know if you're excited to watch
this are you going to watch it what you
thought of season one as well what you
hope to see in season two and i'm of
course gonna do a spoiler review so that
will be out the day the witcher comes
out next friday so please come there
with me and i'll go into detail about
all my thoughts and obviously talk about
the last two episodes as this centipede
is looking at me but uh yeah please
follow me at st harley's show on twitter
instagram and tick tock for more of me
and i'll see you next time